soliman est agriculteur sur l'île de
tutti en plein coeur de l'agglomération
de khartoum
principale source d'approvisionnement en
fruits et légumes de la capitale
soudanaise s'est il se situe au
confluent du nil bleu et du nil blanc
c'est là qu'ils se rejoignent pour
former le nil mais soliman et ses
collègues fermiers sont inquiets le
niveau du nil baisse le niveau de l'eau
est faible par rapport à l'an dernier à
cette époque normalement c'est
impossible pour nous de nous tenir
debout à cette place où même à neuf
mètres d'ici c'est impossible aux aubois
afin de pomper l'eau nous devons mettre
le moteur dans l'eau pour obtenir la
quantité d'eau dont nous avons besoin
pour boire mais aussi pour l'irrigation
selon les autorités soudanaises
l'ethiopie serait directement
responsable de cette situation
la raison le grand barrage de la
renaissance sur le nil bleu un projet
colossal lancée en 2011 par les
éthiopiens pour fournir de l'électricité
à toute leur population
l'ouvragé titanesque cause d'énormes
tensions diplomatiques avec l'egypte et
le soudan
d'une capacité de 74 milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau le réservoir du barrage
pourrait menacer le début du fleuve lors
de son remplissage prévues sur plusieurs
années ce vendredi les autorités
éthiopiennes annoncé avoir atteint le
niveau de remplissage prévu pour la
première année de ce réservoir grâce à
de fortes précipitations
mais pour clarifier les choses l'egypte
et le soudan réclame un accord global
sur la gestion du barrage et du
remplissage de son réservoir
le premier remplissage est terminée vous
savez comment cela s'est passé mais
c'est grâce aux fortes précipitations
cette année et à l'inondation qui a
rempli le barrage whitfield
c'est une victoire pour les éthiopiens
sont d'humeur festive et célèbre le
remplissage du barrage
autre point de contentieux le
fonctionnement du barrage en période de
sécheresse qui n'a toujours pas fait
l'objet d'un accord malgré de longs
pourparlers mais la médiation de l'union
africaine pourrait désamorcer le conflit
l'ethiopie l'egypte et le soudan
d'ailleurs convenu de reprendre leurs
discussions après un contact par
visioconférence il ya quelques jours